au milieu de la crise actuelle de la
vache folle certains producteurs en
france tirent leur épingle du jeu du jeu
pardon il s'agit des éleveurs dits
biologiques
reportage dans l'allier jacques cardoze
france eire un lieu du passé pour une
qualité d'antan autour de ce château
construit sous le second empire
un élevage plutôt rare 210 h répartis
sur 150 hectares et pour les alimenter
de l'herbe sans aucun produit chimique
l'éleveur un homme d'une quarantaine
d'années reconverti à la culture
biologique parce qu allergique aux
engrais prêter
c'était il y a dix ans un retour à
l'authentiqué motivée par
l'environnement et la santé
premièrement c'est beaucoup plus
agréable pour le troupeau beaucoup plus
sain pour le soigneur ont fait des
grosses économies de vétérinaires donc
la viande est meilleur au bout c'est un
des chances qu'on avait complètement
oublié je bouge chance avec est oublié
et la biologie permet de réhabiliter ce
sens
réhabiliter un sens qui a un prix car
cet éleveur est aussi cultivateurs
biologique pour son propre bétail
conséquence la viande est vendue 20 %
plus cher même si la demande est de plus
en plus fort
shaka se rend bien compte qu'on était en
direct c'est que l'agriculture
industrielle apprenez des aliments qui
sont un petit peu trop trafiqué
et qu'aujourd'hui chaque race 30 bien
compte que si on veut retrouver un corps
sainte bien dans son corps il faut
manger bio une viande bio peu
disponibles actuellement sur le marché
il faut dire que les éleveurs sont rares
dans ces conditions difficile
d'atteindre la filière de la grande
distribution
une filière qui a ses préférences pour
la viande classique